it's the last day of the election
campaign according to the latest opinion
polls the former prime minister rosh
cabaret and his MPP party are in front
Percy was he supports women when the MPP
comes to power we will benefit we women
have been suffering a long time we will
win with 54 or sixty percent getting
more wouldn't be good we don't want
soviet-era numbers so via ticular on via
padishah but the supporters of the other
favorite candidate Zephyr hon dr play
are undeterred they say he stands for
fundamental change some CNN is on set
player we're not worried we believe in
fair play we will accept the result but
we are also inviting everyone to
accompany Zephyr Hong to the
presidential palace at 8pm on the 29
raffaella philosopher and a cushy up to
prevent election rigging and promote
transparency a Citizens Coalition has
put together a team of six thousand
election observers they'll be at polling
stations from five thirty in the morning
and will report back to an office in the
capital w liz up there are some super
sized diffuse normally the observers
write everything down on a piece of
paper this year we have something new
they can use smartphones the observers
were very excited by this it's a big
motivation they're happy with how things
are going on dude securing plenty
superseded EU election observers are
also on the ground and they're impressed
by what they've seen so far they've been
here since September and witness the
failed coup attempt their mission has
been strengthened to 124 observers the
campaign has been relatively peaceful
it seems no matter who people support
they're glad to have the opportunity to
vote